this is the machine gun jump shot
Lori and Kohler better known
in the pool one of the best trick shot
artists in the world I've probably
invented over 10 000 new shots can you
name all of them I don't bother naming
them uh sting shots machine gun shots
satellite shots I really don't know they
don't have a name
having spent years honing his craft
Florian's ability to spin and control
pool balls borders on the supernatural
that was thought that's gonna be you
know two years then five years then ten
years now it's like going on to 15 plus
years
[Music]
this is a crisscross twin Messi
so it's a very technical shot
I'm gonna have two cues I'm gonna have
to hit those two cue ball in the same
time the left ball is Right Spin and the
right bow is left spin meaning this ball
I'm gonna hit on the right side and this
ball on the far left side the next part
I got to avoid is contact in the middle
if both touch each other usually no good
if I put too much right spin I may not
have enough backspin and if I put too
much backspin then the balls will come
back in the middle
foreign
messy
a mass sees when you put a lot of spin
on the cue ball by doing a vertical
motion and impacting a lot of force down
so you're going to do bottom and attach
a left spin that's going to propose the
ball forward make it in the corner
the cue ball is gonna then come back
into the other red ball this is also
using what we call a mass AQ so it's a
little heavier than normal pool cue the
shaft is made out of kevlon carbon
because it has to be resistant because
there's a lot of impact and it's a very
damaging shot
Florian's high intensity trick shots
have garnered him thousands of fans as
well as a poisonous nickname every pool
player kind of has a nickname right it's
either given or kind of chosen it sort
of depends right when I first started
because I didn't have any idea how to
play normal pool I went right away with
the very technical damaging shot so
learn how to massly and jump and that
obviously doesn't go very well for your
claws my dad called me in French and
poisoned for the table because he
originally bought this table for himself
couldn't really play on it because it's
too broken up so then somebody's like oh
we should call you Venom and it kind of
stuck
this is a satellite Mass it's super
pretty but very difficult shot
foreign
a few years back he was deemed almost
impossible to do live you're going to
shoot the ball into the rail this short
rail back then this long rail then it's
gonna curve back into the three ball if
you just shoot the ball to the rail it
would do something like this as you can
see our cue ball moves away right to
make that salad messy we got to go
maximum maximum left Spin and a little
bit of Top Spin evens and try to fight
the current to make the Red Bull very
very difficult I'm probably one of the
rare in the world that can do this shot
consistently
am I supposed to be by trading
optometrist but that was a bit boring
for me and I love pool too much so
decided to scrub it and went pool for a
career I can't really advise kids to do
the same because it's kind of a gamble
but I would say I spent a good part of
my college Years being at a pool room
till two in the morning doing a lot more
pool than studying even to this day it
even running for business now at the
same time I still probably put 30 hours
a week in the pool table
the biggest misconception for trick shot
is that it's easy that you can do it all
the time it couldn't be further from the
truth you'd never learn how to make a
shots you learn how to miss them you
learn how to miss on the left you'll
know how to miss on the right you learn
to miss in the middle and that's why
even in tournaments we had three tries
in the world championship you'll have
three tries
story of my life stupid game while it
can take several tries to get each trick
right some of Florian's interactive
shots require expert Precision for this
one I need a volunteer lucky for us we
already have one this is what I call The
Nutcracker let's wish him good luck
because you moved so
this is the jump out of the rock Massey
[Music]
the trick is to jump the ball but
instead of just going forward it has to
come back so you got to find a happy
medium between enough air and the side
Spin and the backspin I try to be very
loose on the backhand too and hit that
with a very pure stroke
spreading his passion for the game
Florian took us to a pool hall to show
us that with the right setup anyone can
make a trick shot even me
so this was the butterfly shots I'm
going to take an extra Bowl here let's
grab the 14. move it right in front of
the keyboard look at the nine ball on
this side make a line with my Q one ball
there
right on line up the two balls so as you
can see the two ball is not lined up
towards the pocket at all same thing
here for the three we're gonna just
repeat the process the 10 ball is
pointed out of it and the 11 is pointed
out this way and the reason is because
the friction so friction was going to
make my ball turn if it was newer there
would be less friction it'll be more
aimed towards the pocket still a bit off
but not quite as far with Florian's
assurances it was easy I decided to give
it a try
if I hit it hard enough it's a little
soft oh rubbed I was wrong
it's a little soft down the wire now
oh it's looking good
there you go that's awesome so physics
once the setup is right pretty much
anybody can do it and there's a little
bit of skill if you hit it perfect but
you made all six balls new personal
record right by far buy at least four
balls and now you're gonna show off with
your friends
why do I think people love watching pool
I think simply because it's something
fascinating about it you could put a
four-year-old on a pool table and I love
to just throw the balls around and see
what happened right
making the balls Bend and curve to his
will Florian has to see the pool table
in a way that no one else does first the
size are you going to go from a bar that
has usually what we call Bar bucks to
professional table which is nine foot
they even make ten foot now there's an
adjustment there then the size of the
pockets again bar you can have white
pockets in your professional table much
smaller the felt itself it's thickness
and then the Bold from low end plastic
Bowl they're very heavy to like what we
have now phenolic resin which is the top
of the line now on top of that you're
gonna have to think about the weather I
know it sounds crazy but humidity
affects pool in a way that's
unimaginable changes everything from
your aiming to the way the ball reacts
people think there's a lot of math
involved yes and no it's not quite as
far as the formula goes you don't
necessarily have to explain it put it
black on white because at the end of the
day there's so much feel to it that it
doesn't really work but if you don't
visualize the angle it's very tricky to
go far with this
this is a railroad shot
the railroad is a pretty old shot
so in my way I'm hitting it here it's
going up table it's coming back down
table then it's gonna have enough
backspin to climb on top of the queues
and then with the speed and the way the
cues are slanted they're gonna roll down
and make the red ball here the hardest
part of this trick is to hit the ball
that perfect on the speed so it doesn't
go off the table or back down so you
just got to find the right right amount
of speed and right amount of spin
foreign
toe table already like a three foot
table and then now we're going even
smaller and those I think are like one
foot tables it's so little that I'm
gonna have to deliver it just right just
like that
this is the egg shot
so I'm gonna put a lot of left spin on
the egg which is by the way the same
material as a normal pool ball the egg
is gonna raise on its side stand up for
a bit and spin
no matter how much time Florence spends
on his home tables or in pool halls he
still views pool in a one-of-a-kind way
a normal player they'll learn a bunch of
preconceived idea about what the game is
and how the ball should move and what's
possible right I think this is the main
difference really I I just had no
preconceived idea just everything was
possible and never put any stop to
anything